sie kommt außen Nordkorea der
Islamischen Republik Iran oder noch
näher an unseren Grenzen aus Russland es
geht um die nukleare Bedrohung das
Risiko eines realen Einsatzes von
Atomwaffen wir alle haben mitbekommen
dass Wladimir Putin und seine
Spießgesellen im Rahmen ihrer
katastrophal Invasion der Ukraine
mehrmals damit gedroht haben Atomwaffen
einzusetzen kurzum das sind nukleare
Risiko also die Möglichkeit von
Atombombenexplosion oder gar eines
veritablen Atomkriegs liegt als Thema
wieder auf dem Tisch dabei ist es gar
nicht so lange her dass wir dachten
wenigstens diese Kelch sei an der
Menschheit vorbeigegangen ich meine
bedeutet der Fall der Berliner Mauer am
09 november 1989 nicht auch dass die
Welt in einer Ära des Friedens des
Wohlstands und freien Handels eintrat
atompel the bombenfest und tief in Berge
gegrabene Kommando Bunker gehörten
plötzlich der Vergangenheit an zumindest
dachten wir das doch jetzt scheint diese
Ära leider wieder vorbei zu sein eine
ganz neue nukleare Nervosität macht sich
Zeit und spiegelt sich in Nachrichten
wie dieser perfekt wieder Pentagon China
wird bis 2035 wahrscheinlich über mehr
als 1500 Atomsprengköpfe verfügen drei
statt zwei nukleare Supermächte Leuten
eine neue strategische Ära ein China ist
auf dem besten Weg sein
Atomwaffenarsenal massiv auszubauen
während Russland den letzten großen
waffenkontrollvertrag aufkündigt dies
ist ein Vorbote einer neuen Welt in der
Peking Moskau und Washington
wahrscheinlich atomar gleich auflegen
werden doch in diesem Video werdet ihr
sehen das nicht nur China sondern auch
Wladimir Putins Russland der atomaren
Aufrüstung höchste Priorität eingeräumt
wir sprechen über einen ganz neues
politisches und militärisches Umfeld das
ist Gleichgewicht der nuklearme Mächte
wie es in kalten Kriege geschmiedet
wurde vollkommen verändert hat und um
diese Veränderung nachhaltig zu
analysieren stellen wir uns hierbei
wieso alle Politik folgende Fragen
welche Länder verfügen heute eigentlich
über Atomwaffen warum scheint der Kreml
Angesicht so viele offener Fronten um
die sich kümmern musste Nuklearbereich
wieder zur vorrangigen Priorität zu
erheben und welche querwiegenden
Konsequenzen könnte ein neues globales
atomares Wettrüsten nach sich ziehen
heute werden wir all diese Fragen
beantworten und zwar sofort nach der
kurzen werbeeinlage des Sponsors der
dieses Video möglich gemacht hat Angie
one von athletic Greens AG One ist ein
außergewöhnliches
Nahrungsergänzungsmittel denn es
kombiniert ganze 75 hochwertige
Inhaltsstoffe auf eine Art und Weise die
eine hohe Bioverfügbarkeit ermöglicht
viele Zuschauer fragen uns ja oft wie
wir es eigentlich schaffen so viele
Videos und so kurzer Zeit zu produzieren
nun dazu gehören natürlich eine perfekte
Koordination im Team und wirklich
langfristige individuelle
Leistungsfähigkeit ich meine es geht ja
nicht darum dass man unbedingt
leistungsfähig sein muss sondern dass
man leistungsfähig sein will weil
Leistung eben Spaß macht nicht wahr der
Schlüssel dazu ist natürlich geistige
und körperliche Fitness und vor allem
eine gute Routine Routinen sind
essentiell um unseren Alltag zu
strukturieren und Körper und Geist auf
Kurs zu halten bei mir sieht diese so
aus dass ich als Nachteule nach dem
Aufstehen und vor dem Frühstück erst
einmal meinen Kreislauf und meine
Mitochondrien in Schwung bringen muss
ideal dafür ist ein wenig Sport
hauptsächlich Krafttraining allerdings
kommt davon noch etwas anderes wichtiges
der Körper will mit Wasser und wichtigen
Nährstoffen versorgt werden allerdings
ohne ihn zu belasten und an dieser
Stelle kommt AG one ins Spiel mit seinen
75 hochwertigen Inhaltsstoffen Vitaminen
Mineralstoffen Botanicals und
Bakterienkulturen gibt es einem genau
für diese aktivierende Morgenroutine den
umfassenden nährstoffkick um aktiv aber
unbelastet in den Tag zu starten das
tolle daran es ist sehr einfach in der
Anwendung seine Mikronährstoffe wurden
aus echten natürlichen Nahrungsmitteln
wie Erbsen oder Soja gewonnen wie gesagt
sind sie in hoher Bio Verfügbarkeit
Verhalten so dass sie besonders gut vom
Körper aufgenommen werden können
außerdem schmeckt es auch noch gut mehr
zumindest aber wartet hier kommt der
Beweis
eine einzige Portion AG wollen das heißt
ein Messlöffel in 250 Milliliter Wasser
versorgt mein Körper nach dem Aufstehen
mit vielen wichtigen Nährstoffen und
dann geht's gleich raus in den Garten um
mit reichlich Sonnenlicht und Bewegung
meinen circa dir einen Rhythmus und
Energiestoffwechsel in Schwung zu
bringen dadurch kann ich mein
Serotoninspiegel anheben und bin
automatisch wacher besser gelaunt und
stelle meine innere Uhr ein und tagsüber
leistungsfähig für das recherchieren
schreiben und Filme zu sein und abends
dann trotz aller Krisen dieser Welt über
die ich dabei nachdenken und Berichten
musste gut einschlafen zu können also
das ist mein Start in den Tag schreibt
mir doch in die Kommentare wie eure
Morgenroutine aussieht und wenn sie
nicht so ideal ist wie ihr sie auf
Vordermann bringen möchtet mein Tipp für
dein Grundbedarf nach dem Aufstehen mit
LG wollen wieder auf und dann ab nach
draußen gerade jetzt wo ist dort wieder
so schön ist passend dazu bietet Greens
unsere Community ein exklusives früheres
Angebot wenn du auf den Link in der
Videobeschreibung klickst erhältst du
bei Abschluss eines monatlichen Abos
einen kostenlosen Jahresvorrat an
Vitamin D3 und K2 und die praktische LG1
travel Packs für unterwegs gratis
neukunden erhalten außerdem das LG und
welcome Camp inklusive schicke
Aufbewahrungsdose und einem praktischen
Shaker zur Monatspackung dazu ach und
vor dem Abo brauchst du auch keine Angst
zu haben du kannst es nämlich jederzeit
pausieren kündigen oder lieferrhythmus
nach Belieben anpassen das ist aber noch
nicht alles um dir die Entscheidung noch
leichter zu machen bietet LG born einen
90 Tage Geld zurück Garantie stellst du
also nach drei Monaten fest dass es
einfach nicht zu Dir passt bekommst du
das Geld für die erste Bestellung
einfach wieder zurück ohne dass du dafür
irgendwelche Gründe angeben musst also
worauf wartest du noch probiere LG one
doch einfach mal aus und bringt auch
deine Ernährung unter Routine auf
Vordermann und schreibt mir dann hier in
den angebinden Kommentar wie eure
Erfahrungen waren ja uns würde diese
wirklich interessieren so und nun lasst
uns wieder zur Beantwortung unserer
brennenden Fragen kommen warum erklärt
der Kreml den Nuklearbereich wieder zur
vorrangigen Priorität und welche
Konsequenzen könnte ein neues globales
atomares betrüsten haben aufgepasst
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die Angst vor einem nuklearen Armageddon
prägte einen Großteil der zweiten Hälfte
des 20 Jahrhunderts denn nach dem
Zweiten Weltkrieg erwarten nach und nach
immer mehr Staaten den Status eine Atom
macht es war die Sowjetunion die auch
nur vier Jahren das atomare Monopol der
USA bereits wieder beendete bekanntlich
hatte ja Washington mit seinen
Atombombenabwürfen auf Hiroshima und
mangasaki im August 1945 den Zweiten
Weltkrieg im Pazifikraum ein Ende
gesetzt 1952 zu Großbritannien nach 1960
dann Frankreich und schließlich gelang
auch 1964 China ein erfolgreicher
atombombenfest damit war die
Fünfergruppe der klassischen Atommächte
komplett bei denen es sich nicht
zufällig auch um die fünf ständigen
Mitglieder des UN-Sicherheitsrates
handelte allerdings waren die
Sowjetunion und die Vereinigten Staaten
mit Abstand die beiden Hauptakteure in
diesen neuen rüstungsrennen zusammen
verfügten sie über fast 70% des globalen
Waffenarsenals und wie in dieser Grafik
sehen könnt waren sie auch für
1745 der etwa 2000 weltweit
durchgeführten Atombombentests
verantwortlich wenn es schon allein so
viele Tests gab dann ist auch gut
nachvollziehbar dass in den Arsenalen
der Atommächte nicht nur ein paar
Dutzend atombombenlagen nein ganz Ungarn
nicht in der Anfangsphase des Kalten
Krieges stoppten die Sowjetunion und die
USA ihre Lagerbestände wie verrückt auf
um euch ein Beispiel zu geben 1962 wäre
der Kubakrise war der rote Knopf im
Weißen Haus bereits mit 25000 540
atomspringen Köpfen verbunden zu diesem
Zeitpunkt hatte die Sowjetunion nur
3346 Sprengköpfe aber sie sollte bald
aufholen in den 70er Jahre die USA sogar
zahlenmäßig überrunden insgesamt
erreichte der weltweite bestanden 1980er
Jahre sein Höhepunkt mit schätzungsweise
70.000
ja ich weiß das klingt einfach nur
verrückt
[Musik]
aber das meine Lieben Zuschauer war
Folge und Ausdruck der Doktrin der
gegenseitig zugesicherten Zerstörung
umgangssprachlich auch das Gleichgewicht
des Schreckens genannt der englische
Fachbegriff dafür lautet usually assured
destruction kurz mad was passenderweise
auch als mad also verrückt gewesen
werden kann dieses Gleichgewicht
bedeutet das sowohl die USA als auch die
Sowjetunion im atomaren Wettlauf soweit
gegangen waren dass bei den Ernstfall
einfach vernichtet werden würden wenn
nur einer den anderen angreifen würde
und nicht nur diese beiden Länder selbst
sondern wohl auch noch einen großen Teil
des Rest der Welt gleich mit aber das
ist ja alles gut bekannt darüber wurde
schon mehr als genug gesprochen die
Wahrheit hinter dieser Verrücktheit ist
aber auch dass die Abschreckung
funktioniert hat denn hey wir leben ja
noch Rückblicken sieht es also so aus
als hätte die Doktrin der gegenseitig
zugesicherten Zerstörung die Welt
entgegen aller Intuitionen er sicherer
gemacht aber wisst ihr was das Risiko
und das Problem dabei war macht euch
einfach mal aus was bedeutet
Zehntausende von Atombomben vorzuhalten
die jederzeit auch durch einen
Missverständnis einen Terrorakt oder
menschliches Versagen hätten gezündet
werden können schwupps die Bobs hätte
die globale Katastrophe plötzlich da
sein können und es hätte kein Zurück
mehr gegeben denn logisch ist auch je
mehr Waffen man hat es so schwieriger
ist ist sie richtig zu kontrollieren
desto wahrscheinlicher ist es dass die
Kontrollmechanismen versagen und dass
diese heikle-technologie in fremde Hände
gerät genau aus diesem Grund haben die
beiden möchte verstanden dass sie etwas
unternehmen müssen genauer gesagt das
ist Vereinbarungen braucht um diese
Gefahren zu minimieren
[Musik]
und so wurde 1968 der Atomwaffen
Sperrvertrag geboren ein internationales
Abkommen das den Wettlauf vieler Länder
um den Erwerb dieser Art von Waffen
bremste und nicht nur das 1972 wurde
auch der erste Vertrag zur Begrenzung
strategischer Waffen salt-one
geschlossen dieses Abkommen begrenzte
die Anzahl der ballistischen
Interkontinentalraketen und
ballistischen U-Boote der USA und der
Sowjetunion im Jahr 1979 gingen sie mit
der Unterzeichnung von Souls 2 sogar
noch weiter das Ergebnis dieser
Vereinbarung nun sieht es euch an wie
ihr seht ebneten die salt Verträge den
Weg für die Reduzierung der
Atomwaffenarsenale aber sie blieben
nicht die einzigen 1987 unterzeichneten
die beiden Supermächte einen Vertrag zu
Begrenzung der nuklearen
mittelstreckenwaffen und ab 1991 als
sich die Sowjetunion auflöstete Russland
dieselbe Politik fort und zwar indem es
in den USA die Abkommen Star Wars eine
verbesserte Version von Salt natürlich
gab der Zusammenbruch das wird Union den
Vereinigten Staaten wieder die globale
wie ihr in der Grafik gesehen habt hatte
Russland zwar mehr Atomwaffen aber viele
davon waren alt ineffizient und ihre
Einsatzmöglichkeiten waren stärker
eingeschränkt den USA hingegen war es
gelungen moderne strategische Bomber wie
die B2 Atom-U-Boote und
intercontinentalraketen mit viel höherer
Präzision und Zuverlässigkeit zu
entwickeln ganz zu schweigen von neuen
Raketen Abwehrsystemen wie den
[Musik]
tashday ist nicht kennen die aged ist
ein System das ballistische Mittel und
Langstreckenraketen abfangen kann da ist
mobil ist kann es große Gebiete oder
ganze Metropolen schützen das System
nutzt ein Hightech Radar und feindliche
Raketen zu erkennen und zu verfolgen und
ihre Flugbahn in Echtzeit hat andere
gekoppelte Raketenabwehrsysteme zu
übermitteln darüber wie teenage die die
Chinesen in Südkorea nervös macht haben
wir sogar ein eigenes Video gedreht
daneben gibt es noch ages ein ähnliches
System das aber auf griechische
stationiert ist gegen taktische
Nuklearwaffen haben die USA z.B das
Patches System in petto dazu aber später
mehr um sich vor der ganz großen
Apokalypse zu schützen haben sie das NMD
Raketen ab der System dies ist ein
landgestütztes System zur Abwehr
ballistischer interkontinental Raketen
in dieses Projekt haben die Vereinigten
Staaten seit Beginn des 21 Jahrhundert
über 100 Milliarden Dollar investiert
und nach wie vor genießt dieser im
Aufbau befindliche nukleare Schutzschirm
viel Aufmerksamkeit und bekommt direkt
zugewiesen
es überrascht nicht das in diesem Sektor
den wirtschaftliche und technologisch
Überlegenheit der USA offensichtlich
wird wir können also konstatieren dass
im atompoker aus der gegenseitig
zugesicherten Zerstörung erst eine Art
gegenseitig zugesichertes Vertrauen
wurde obwohl in Wahrheit des
Gleichgewicht zunehmend zugunsten der
amerikanischen Vormachtstellung in
Schieflage gerät die Eigenschaften der
beiden atomwaffensysteme erschwerten
jede praktikable Definition des
Gleichgewichts die sowjetischen
strategischen Systeme waren riesig und
unpräzise die US-Waffen waren
transportabler und präziser Henry
kissenger in leadership aus diesem Grund
hat der Kreml in den letzten Jahren
wieder begonnen sich über die
Erweiterung und Erneuerung seiner
strategischen Fähigkeiten Gedanken zu
machen aber bevor wir uns diese
Initiativen vornehmen wollte erst einmal
detailliert untersuchen wie die aktuelle
Lage auf der Atomwaffen Welt eigentlich
genau aussieht und deswegen meine Lieben
Zuschauer führen wir erst einmal eine
richtige Inventur durch beim Arsenal des
atomaren Schreckens
die Atomwaffen des 21 Jahrhunderts
zunächst mal eine überraschende Tatsache
die richtig gut klingt der einstige
rekordbestand von etwa 70.000 Atombomben
weltweit ist heute auf weniger als
14.000 gesunken und das obwohl Pakistan
Israel Indien und Nordkorea erst später
dem elitären Club der Atommächte
beigetreten sind tatsächlich haben mit
Ausnahme von China alle historischen
Atommächte also die Länder die ihren
ständigen Sitz im Sicherheitsrat der
Vereinten Nation haben ihre
atomwaffenarsen alle deutlich reduziert
diese Grafik gibt euch eine Vorstellung
davon wer aktuell auf der Welt wie viele
atomspektköpfe bereithält aber hat bitte
für eines Verständnis angesichts der
massiven Geheimhaltung in diesem Sektor
handelt es sich bei diesen Zahlen
natürlich um Schätzungen
wie ihr seht hat sich die schrittweise
Reduzierung der Gesamtzahl der
Atomsprengköpfe immer weiter fortgesetzt
seit den 1970er Jahren haben die
Vereinigten Staaten etwa 80% ihres
Arsenals vernichtet und die Sowjetunion
respektive Russland sogar 90%.
zusätzlich zu den bereits getroffenen
Vereinbarungen unterzeichnete damaligen
Präsidenten Barack Obama und mit 2010 in
Prag das newstart Abkommen dieser neue
Vertrag sah alles zusätzliche
Reduzierung des Arsenals beide Länder um
ein Drittel vor er beinhaltete die
Liquidierung von etwa 1.750 atomköpfen
auf jeder Seite 2021 wurde dieses
Abkommen um weitere 5 Jahre verlängert
obwohl die Einhaltung der Vereinbarung
durch Russland stark in Frage gestellt
wird ja jetzt kommt aber das große ABER
denn weniger Waffen bedeutet nicht
unbedingt weniger Stärke die
US-amerikanische LGM 30g Management 3
und die russische rs28 Sarah matt also
die interkontinental Raketen dieser
beiden Länder schlechthin haben jeweils
eine 500 bis 1500 Mal höhere
Zerstörungskraft als little boy so hieß
jede Bombe die 1945 über Hiroshima
abgeworfen wurde
und an dieser Stelle gibt es doch eine
weitere wichtige Anmerkung Länder wie
Nordkorea das vielleicht gerade einmal
über einen Dutzend Atombomben verfügt
oder der Iran wenn er denn tatsächlich
die Bombe fertig bekommen sollte stellt
ebenfalls ein großes Risiko für die
globale Sicherheit dar vielleicht ist es
sogar viel größer als wir denken und
warum nun wegen des Risikos der
Informalität denn wir reden hier von
zwei paria-staaten die sehr
intransparent sind und deren Eliten sich
vom Rest der Welt sehr stark abgekoppelt
haben zwei Länder die ist oben drei
gewohnt sind mit einer Formel Ausdruck
Nötigung und Erpressung zu verhandeln um
ihre Ziele zu erreichen solche Länder
könnten selbst den Beginn eines großen
internationalen Konflikt provozieren es
ist also davon auszugehen dass Nordkorea
bald in der Lage sein wird die
Vereinigten Staaten direkt mit
ballistischen Raketen anzugreifen das
würde es benjam ermöglichen sein Einsatz
bei jedem Verhandlung zu erhöhen was
automatisch zu viel stärkeren Spannungen
führt von einem möglichen scheitern ganz
zu schweigen
nordkorea verfügt über genügend
Intercontinental Raketen um das
Verteidigungssystem der USA zu
überwinden eine US-Regierung nach der
anderen hat es versäumt Nordkorea davon
abzuhalten eine solche große Zahl von
Geschossen zu entwickeln die theoretisch
die USA erreichen können eine weiteres
Pulver erfasst ist natürlich Pakistan
ein Land das in den nächsten Jahren
kollabieren könnte aber darüber haben
wir bereits Videos gedreht und aus all
diesen Gründen natürlich auch wegen des
Auftauchens neue Raketen beschleunigt
das Pentagon die Pläne für die
Entwicklung von Raketenabwehrsystem
[Musik]
einiges scheint schon vorhanden zu sein
es werden von der us-rüstungsindustrie
aber sogar praktisch von Grund auf neue
Abwehrsysteme entwickelt zum Beispiel
gibt es da ein Projekt namens next
generation intercepter dieses lgi wäre
ein völlig neuer raketenschutzschirm der
Inferno Zukunft über den USA aufgespannt
werden können die raketenabwehragentur
fordert 10,9 Milliarden Dollar im
Haushaltsjahr 2024 und dutzende
Milliarden in den Folgejahren
Nordamerika scheint also schon jetzt
relativ gut gegen atomare Attacken
geschützt zu sein und in Zukunft wird es
das noch besser aber es ist halt auch
vorstellbar das genau aus diesem Grund
nicht die USA direkt angegriffen werden
sondern ein anderes Land wie Japan
Südkorea oder Europa und auch dann wäre
die kolossale Katastrophe da und ja sie
könnte einen neuen wirklich globalen
Konflikt auslösen aber einmal abgesehen
von diesen Risiken die einerseits sehr
besonderes erregend sind aber
andererseits auch von geringer
Wahrscheinlichkeit der jetzt
entscheidende Punkt ist dass der
russische Krieg in der Ukraine die
politische und militärische Landschaften
noch einmal komplett
verändert hat die Frage lautet also wo
genau stehen wir heute und warum haben
wir zu Beginn dieses Videos gesagt das
sind diesen Zusammenhang Putins atomker
besonders wichtig ist nun all das werden
wir uns jetzt ganz genau ansehen also
aufgepasst
welche Krallen hat der russische Bär
heute
Wladimir Putin löste 2012 matt wird
jetzt wieder ab und kehrte ins
Präsidentenamt zurück nur zwei Jahren
nach der Unterzeichnung von new start
obwohl der russische Diktator sich 2021
für eine Verlängerung der Gültigkeit des
Vertrags um 5 Jahre aussprach stand
Putin der nuklearen Abrüstung immer
kritisch gegenüber sagen wir es mal so
er ist der Meinung dass dies ein Weg sei
der darauf abziele den russischen Bären
zu bändigen und das Mütterchen Russland
eigentlich ein ganz anderen Weg
einschlagen sollte wie also steht es um
das new Startup kommen derzeit nun wie
wäre es mit einer Gegenfrage was macht
das überhaupt für einen Unterschied wie
wir alle inzwischen nur zu gut wissen
erfüllt der Kreml seine Verpflichtungen
ohne hin und dann wenn sie ihm in den
Kram passen an diejenigen die in den
letzten 15 Jahren versucht haben ein
Wettrüsten zu beschleunigen und ein
einseitigen Vorteil gegenüber Russland
zu suchen alles was Sie mit dieser
Politik zu verhindern versucht haben ist
bereits geschehen niemandem ist es
gelungen in Russland aufzuhalten
Wladimir Putin im Jahr 2018 nachdem eine
Reihe von ologischen Durchbrüchen in
russischen Atom Arsenal angekündigt
hatte aus realpolitischer Sicht macht
eine solche Haltung sehr viel Sinn denn
für routinierte visualpolitik Zuschauer
ist es sicher keine große Überraschung
was ich jetzt sagen werde die einzige
reale Macht über die Russland heute
verfügt in seinem Atomwaffenarsenal ohne
seine Atombomben wäre dieses riesige
Land heute praktisch nichts als eine
billig Tankstelle für China und
vielleicht noch für Indien
tja so weit hat Putin sein Reich
gebracht wir haben dieses Problem schon
in mehreren Videos auseinandergenommen
und ich werde sie euch verlinken damit
ihr sie euch im Anschluss ansehen könnt
falls ihr sie verpasst haben solltet
übrigens habt ihr eigentlich schon
unseren Kanal abonniert wenn nicht dann
holt das jetzt doch bitte ganz schnell
nach und bitte auch das Glöckchen
aktivieren ist dieses stellt ja
heutzutage das eigentliche Abo da und
wenn ihr das erledigt habt schnell
wieder zurück zum Thema also was wäre
das heutige Russland ohne seine Atom
Droge nun es handelt sich um ein
drastisch über alterndes Land mit
stufener Bevölkerung wissenschaftlich
und technologisch ist es abgehängt seine
Wirtschaft liegt seit Jahren am Boden
und das gleiche gilt für die Moral der
Bevölkerung und der konventionellen
Streitkräfte diese sind ja noch nicht
einmal in der Lage die Armee der viermal
kleineren und wesentlich ärmeren Ukraine
zu besiegen Russlands einziger Trump
sind derzeit nur nukleare Drohungen oder
besser gesagt nukleare Erpressung
Boris Johnson behauptet Putin habe ihn
gedroht eine Rakete auf Großbritannien
abzuschießen der Kreml sagt er Lüge
Lampe auf Wand davor die Gefahr eines
Atomkriegs zu unterschätzen solche
Drohungen haben ihren Teil dazu
beigetragen dass die militärische Hilfe
für die Ukraine langsamer kam als es in
einem anderen Kontext wurde der Fall
gewesen wäre und auch wenn sie nicht so
recht funktioniert haben Droge werden
mit der atomkeule wurden in Moskau seit
den Kriegsausbruch immer wieder gerne
verbal hervorgeholt
jetzt sagt Waffenlieferungen an Kiew
beschwörten eine globale Atomkatastrophe
heraus
die Gefahr eines Atomkriegs wächst
klingt finster nicht wahr aber wisst ihr
was russland steht hier vor zwei großen
Problemen zum einen ist ein großer Teil
seines Arsenals hoffnungslos veraltet an
der Front in der Ukraine haben wir
bereits die enormen Probleme mit der
Technologie Zuverlässigkeit über
Alterung und Wartung der russischen
Kriegsausrüstung gesehen es gibt keinen
vernünftigen Grund zu glauben dass es
bei den mitunter auch uralten
Gerätschaften in Nuklearbereich anders
aussieht und das andere Problem ist wie
vorhin schon skizziert entwickeln die
USA ständig neue Raketenabwehrsysteme
[Musik]
sollten die USA ein effektives
großräumig wirksames System bekommen
wäre es mit Russlands
abschreckungsfähigkeit aus und vorbei
der Wettbewerbsdruck auf dem Gebiet der
strategischen Nuklearwaffen könnte auch
durch russlandseinschätzung der
us-raketenabwehrfähigkeiten bedingt sein
Moskau hat gezeigt dass es große
Anstrengungen unternehmen und erhebliche
Kosten auf sich nehmen wird um
sicherzustellen dass eine strategischen
nuklear Streitkräfte die
US-Raketenabwehr zuverlässig überwinden
können das erklärt warum wir in den
letzten Jahren so viel über neue
strategische Waffensysteme gehört haben
mit denen der Kreml angeblich die USA in
Schach halten kann und warum der Kreml
beschlossen hat dass das arme Russland
mit seiner depressiven Wirtschaft
dennoch enorme Ressourcen für neue Atom
U-Boote Überschau Raketen und
strategische Waffen bereitzustellen hat
daraus ergeben sich danach richten der
letzten Monate wie die folgende die
russische Marine erhält eine Apokalypse
zu Realisierung von Putins strategischen
Drohungen Poseidon ist eine von Moskau
vor 5 Jahren angekündigte Waffe der
nächsten Generation
sie ist in der Lage Küstenstädte zu
zerstören und Marine Verbände unentdeckt
anzugreifen Russland testet neue
Hyperschall Rakete bei Übungen mit China
und Südafrika
russland baut seine nukleare U-Boot
Flotte rapide aus und ja ich weiß was
die große Mehrheit von euch sich jetzt
denkt Mensch mag was redest du da die
Russen sind doch nicht einmal in der
Lage ihre kämpfende Armee vernünftig
auszurüsten und schicken schon allerlei
oldtime Panzer an die Front und was ist
außerdem mit den Sanktionen
naja es stimmt natürlich ich meine wenn
etwas auf den Kriegsschauplatz Ukraine
deutlich geworden ist dann dass die
realen russischen Fähigkeiten gelinde
gesagt fragwürdig sind aber der andere
Punkt ist eben dass der militärische
Nuklearsektor in Krimmel besonders hohe
Priorität genießt denn Putins politische
Weltgeltung und vielleicht sogar sein
banales nacktes überleben hängen von
Russlands atomare abschreckungsfähigkeit
ab doch es geht hier nicht nur um Putin
persönlich und auch nicht ausschließlich
um die große strategische Ausrüstung
oder Aufrüstung Russlands seht euch mal
das hier an Russland rostet viele seine
Atomwaffen mit kürzere Reichweite nach
und führt neue Typen dieser sogenannten
nicht strategischen Atomwaffen ein ein
Teil der Begründung ist das nicht
strategische Atomwaffen benötigt werden
und der Überlegenheit der
konventionellen Streitkräfte der NATO zu
begegnen mit anderen Worten es geht dem
krämme sowohl um schwere
interkontinentale atomare Waffen die die
USA in Schreckstarre versetzen sollen
als auch um kleinere leichte
herzustellen der Atomwaffen die das alte
Europa in Angst versetzen können und
bedenkt bitte auch solche militärischen
Fähigkeiten könnten bei irgendwann
einmal anstehenden Verhandlungen über
den ukraine-konflikt geradezu
entscheidend sein um für Russland das
maximal mögliche herauszuholen die
Vorstellung des Krems ist dabei wenn man
Druck auf Kiew ausüben will gibt es doch
nichts besseres als dessen Freunde zu
verängstigen Putin sagt moskau werde in
Weißrussland Atomwaffen stationieren die
USA reagiert zurückhaltend das Problem
dabei ist dass dies einen entscheidenden
Paradigmenwechsel darstellt etwas bis
dato nicht da gewesen ist nun viele
denken dass die UdSSR Video USA während
des Kalten Krieges ihr riesiges
Atomwaffenarsenal auch munter eingesetzt
haben um nach links und rechts zu drohen
und andere zu terrorisieren aber halt
fakt ist genau das war eben nicht der
Fall denn dieses Thema wurde sehr viel
vorsichtige und sensibler gehandhabt als
heute durch die Putin klicke
die Sowjetunion hat in Afghanistan nie
mit einem Einsatz von Atomwaffen gedroht
trotz der Unterstützung von
Oppositionsgruppen durch die Vereinigten
Staaten nicht in Afghanistan und auch
nicht anderswo die USA haben auch nie
damit gedroht zum Beispiel in Vietnam
Atomwaffen einzusetzen und zwar auch
nicht wenn ihnen das Wasser bis zum Hals
stand dabei hätten beide Supermächte
damals ja mehr als genug Atomwaffen in
den Depots gehabt wie wir vorhin gesehen
haben das war's denn jetzt tut und auch
in Nordkorea und vielleicht auch noch
die Iran Steuer toller als wenn sie die
Bombe bekommen ist etwas völlig anderes
als früher eine ganz andere Kategorie
von atomarer Bedrohung und damit etwas
das im Westen alle Alarmglocken
schrillen lässt die Gefahr eines realen
Atomkriegs ist so mit heute viel höher
als im Kalten Krieg und was ist die
unmittelbare Folge davon nun die
Vereinigten Staaten müssen ihre Raketen
Abwehr viel viel ernster nehmen dies
jedoch auch für Europa zu erreichen
könnte sich aufgrund der Entfernung und
es ist Zeitaufwands als extrem schwierig
erweisen aber Hoffnung geben zumindest
Nachrichten wie diese
18.05.2023 kinshall gegen patret ein
weiteres mieses Ergebnis für den Kreml
trotz gegenteiliger Beteuerung des
Kremls in die russischen Hyperschall
Marschflugkörper vom Typ kenjal
gegenüber den ukrainischen Patrick Luft
ab das Systemen aus den USA hochgradig
verwundbar was die unabfangbaren
kinschall betrifft so haben die von der
ukrainischen Armee betriebenen Patriots
alle sechs aus der Attacke von Mittwoch
abgeschossen die russische kinderrakete
die von Moskau als alle NATO
Langstreckenwaffen überlegen angepriesen
wird und in der Lage sein soll jedes
Luftverteidigungssystem der Welt zu
überwinden insbesondere das
US-amerikanische Patrick System ist eine
ballistische Rakete die von einem
hochfliegenden Flugzeug aus abgefeuert
wird und nach Angaben ihrer
Konstrukteure auf eine Geschwindigkeit
von macht 10 beschleunigen kann
russische staatlich kontrollierte Medien
haben wiederholt behauptet die Waffe sei
nicht abfangen Bar billiger und
effektiver als westliches Systeme und
ein wichtiger Bestandteil der nuklearen
abschreckungsmacht des Krems unabhängige
und Militär Experten sagten dass das
halbe Dutzend am Mittwoch über Tiere
abgeschossen wurde das Gegenteil der
diese Werbung bewiesen hat das in einem
echten Krieg kostspielige Investitionen
in bessere Technologie und deren
gründliche Erprobung zur realen
Ergebnissen auf dem Schlachtfeld führen
und in der Ukraine bedeutet das dass
sich die besseren Waffen nicht in
russische Hand befinden General Charles
Flynn Kommandeur de pazifischen
Streitkräfte der US-Armee sagte dass das
Pentagon nie aufgehört habe dass in den
1990er Jahren entwickelte Patrick System
aufzurüsten es sei speziell für das
abfallende russische und chinesischer
Lenkraketen modernisiert und optimiert
und werde die Art und Weise verändern
wie die Russen und ihre ukrainischen
Gegner in Zukunft kämpfen werden ja also
manche verdächtigte die USA gab sie
hätten mit der Lieferung der
patricksysteme vor allem deswegen so
lange gezögert damit die Russen nicht
erfahren dass die ab 2016 gefertigten
patri MSI Abfall Raketen doch
tatsächlich in der Lage sind die
neuesten russischen Hyperschall
wunderbar Waffen zu gut 100% abzufangen
denn so wohltuend ist auch sein mag dass
man in der russischen Militärführung nun
in heller Panik sein dürfte noch besser
ist es halt wenn der Feind nicht weiß
über welche Fähigkeiten man tatsächlich
verfügt und nun wissen es halt sowohl
die Russen als auch die Chinesen ihre
hyperschallraketen haben einen
effektiven Konter dabei waren gerade die
russischen kinjas mit taktischen Atom
Sprengköpfen bestückt der große Joker
des Geheimnis gewesen und haben sich nun
als totaler rohrkapierer erwiesen damit
löst sich das druckpotenzial eines
taktischen Atomkriegs durch Russland
quasi in Luft auf der Worst Case für den
Kreml wäre ja wenn sie tatsächlich
versuchen würden nuklear bestückte
Kinder als taktisch einzusetzen und
diese dann einfach abgefangen würden
Russland würde dann als der absolute
Paria da stehen auch gegenüber China und
Indien oder dadurch militärisch auch nur
einen Millimeter vorangekommen zu sein
taktische Atomwaffen gegen die Ukraine
einzusetzen wäre der ultimative Game
Over zu Putins
[Musik]
darüber hinaus haben die USA klargemacht
dass sie den Einsatz taktische
Atomwaffen durch Russland in der Ukraine
als Kasus belly ansehen und danach
sofort zur total Liquidierung der
russischen Staatsführung wieder
Streitkräfte durch ihre eigene geballte
und weit überlegene Militärmaschinerie
übergehen würden und zwar jetzt noch
viel viel mehr als noch vor ein paar
Monaten damals haben wir bereits in
einem Video thematisiert wie schlecht
der Einsatz taktische Atomwaffen für
Putin wäre natürlich werde ich euch das
Video verlinken ist es also tatsächlich
möglich eine Art nuklearen eiernom eine
eiserne Kuppel über Europa zu errichten
wahrscheinlich ja schätzungen zufolge
verfügen die USA über weit mehr als
10.000 Pack 3 MSR Raketen man bräuchte
natürlich auch ein dichtes Netz aus
abschlussblattformen die einen engen
Gürtel um Russland bilden würden ja die
würde eine Menge Geld kosten sogar eine
enorme Menge aber was meint ihr sollte
es einem Europa das z.B riesiges Summen
in den Klimaschutz investiert die
Sicherheit vor einem Atomkrieg nicht
auch etwas wert sein nun alles scheint
darauf hinzudeuten dass die Antwort ja
lauten muss denn krasse
Unzuverlässigkeit politisches
wabbon-spiel und militärischer Irrsinn
der mittlerweile nicht nur von Pjöngjang
sondern auch von Moskau demonstriert
wird bedeutet für uns das bloße
Abschreckung nicht mehr ausreichen
könnte was Europa braucht ist die aktive
Abwehr gegen einen Atomkrieg die
Kernfrage lautet dabei wird Europa
tatsächlich etwas in dieser Richtung
Unternehmen nun sein wir ehrlich
wahrscheinlich nicht und darin meine
Lieben visualpolitik Zuschauer liegt
eben der ganz große Trumpf auf den
Moskau immer noch setzen kann um in
Europa sein Einfluss zu waren und
mittelfristig Zugeständnisse zu
erreichen und das ist der Grund warum
Putin und vermutlich auch seine
Nachfolger trotz allem was passiert ist
und so passieren wird an mächtigen und
zumindestens moderaten modernen
festhalten werden ganz egal was ist
Russland kostet tja vielleicht wird es
mal wieder das gespannt aus Ukraine und
USA sein müssen das einfach in der
Ukraine die zentrale europäische Atom
Abwehr gegen Russland in Eigenregie
aufbauen muss und Europa kann dann davon
quasi kostenlos profitieren denn die
jüngsten Erfolge der Patrick Systeme
scheinen zumindest in Washington nun so
gut wie alle Bedenken über das atomare
Druckpotential Russlands zerstreut zu
haben sie dürften eine der Hauptfaktoren
für die Entscheidung über die Lieferung
der F16 Kampfjets gewesen sein
22.05.2023 wie bei beiden zu seinem Jahr
zu F16 an die Ukraine kamen seit mehr
als einem Jahr bittet Kiew um moderne
Kampfflugzeuge und die Antwort der
beiden Regierung lautete entweder nein
oder nicht jetzt das änderte sich Ende
letzter Woche als Präsident Joe Biden
den Verbündeten mitteilte dass er eine
internationale Koalition unterstützen
würde die ukrainische Piloten auch
westlichen Kampfflugzeugen ausbildet und
damit den Weg dafür ebnet dass moderne
Jets eines Tages an die Frontlinie
verlegt werden können das Pentagon und
hochere Militärs machten sich seit
langem Sorgen über das
eskalationspotential auf russischer
Seite sollte der besten einen Schritt
wie die Bereitstellung von F 16
Kapazitäten für die Ukraine Unternehmen
doch US-Außenminister blinken konnte
während in den letzten Jahres beobachten
das Russland selten über Rhetorik
hinausgeht selbst wenn der Westen mehr
Militärhilfe in die Ukraine eindringt
etwas amüsant ist dabei auch das
Schauspiel das all jene abliefern die
sich bisher vehement gegen die Lieferung
der Kampfjets an die Ukraine gestellt
haben sie geben nun vor ihr Widerstand
sei eigentlich Teil eines taktischen
verwirrspüls gegenüber dem Kreml gewesen
ob sie wirklich die Wahrheit sagen
können auch wir nicht wissen aber ich
denke dass wir jetzt genug Stoff zum
Grübeln haben und deshalb seid ihr an
der Reihe bei unseren traditionellen
Abschluss fragen was meint ihr in wie
war das nukleare Risiko wieder gestiegen
ist glaubt ihr das Putin Russland in der
Lage sein wird seine
abschreckungsfähigkeit zu erhalten
werden die USA in der Lage sein einfach
alle mal einen wirksames
Raketenabwehrsystem zu entwickeln und
wie können sich die europäische schützen
was müssen wir angesichts der neuen
nuklearen Bedrohung tun der Ring für die
Debatte ist frei schreib bitte eure
Meinungen in die Kommentare ich hoffe
dass euch dieses Video gefallen hat und
ihr vielleicht etwas dabei gelernt habt
falls ja gibt uns ein Like und teilt es
mit euren Freunden um es ausgiebig mit
Ihnen zu diskutieren natürlich freuen
wir es auch jederzeit über eine Spende
von euch dieses Projekt weiterzuführen
den Link dazu findet ihr in der
Beschreibung unter dem Video macht's gut
und bis bald
[Musik]